[Music]
hey what's up guys and welcome back to
Souls news I did not expect to see you
back here so soon I feel like we just
got off the hype train for tuck Souls
too but now it seems like we're destined
to get back on it next stop demon souls
2 or something similar so the facts the
other day images from a game with the
working title project-based surfaced
online on an anonymous image board and
this was alongside the following text
from the original poster I quote he
walked around fours enemies I can
describe a giant mind flayer type enemy
a character placed a shining magic sword
into a pedestal at the base of a statue
a huge pyromancy fireball shotguns and
there was also the text this is a
nightmare now I'm going to explain just
how excited and happy this makes me a
little bit later in the video but
unfortunately before we get excited we
need to know are these leaks real and I
think we have the reason to believe that
they are I think everything points
towards project based being another
souls game by from software which would
make use of the demon souls IP owned by
Sony so I'll try and explain my logic
now for starters these screenshots look
like screenshots of video footage of a
game and the game definitely looks like
another iteration of the soul series
you'll notice there's a corpse here that
has a soul item floating above it in the
souls series style as well as what could
be a soul absorption animation here in
the foreground and a beautiful next-gen
looking folk gate also the codename
project based is reminiscent of project
dark and as you might know from zko
named project dark ended up becoming
Dark Souls so it's safe to say that if
these shots are real then it's a new
Souls game but even without these
screenshots it's been rumored for a long
time that a new Souls game would be made
and this is something separate from Dark
Souls and I've been wanting to go into
detail on this topic for ages I feel
like not enough people know the nature
of the demon souls IP and the Dark Souls
IP so a bit of a history lesson in 2009
from software release demon's souls in
Japan with assistance from SCE Japan
studio which is a production armor
Sony and Sony published the game in
Japan but they didn't see much value in
the product president of Sony's
worldwide studios
Shuhei Yoshida called the game
unbelievably bad and Sony didn't pursue
a Western release on this basis but then
after this two companies saw the value
in publishing this game for a Western
audience Atlas came along and published
the game in North America and Namco
Bandai published the game for Australia
and Europe both in 2010 and this is
where it became a cult hit within
Western audiences after seeing this
success from software then apparently
ditched Sony and partnered with Namco
Bandai to create a spiritual successor
to Demon Souls which became the Dark
Souls series that you know and love so
why didn't from make Demon Souls 2 well
it's because Sony owns the rights to the
Demon Souls IP and from saw more value
in partnering with Namco Bandai and
bringing the series cross-platform to
Western audiences with dark souls that
Demon Souls IP has sat unused for years
with the president of Sony Shuhei
Yoshida saying in 2012 that not growing
the Demon Souls IP was one of the
biggest mistakes they make we dropped
the ball he said he then went on to say
our business is to grow our IP and we
love Demon Souls from software is a very
important business partner so we'll see
fast-forward to now and you have the ps4
shaping up to be the biggest success in
console history selling seven million
units worldwide to consumers but the one
thing it's lacking is exclusive titles
games to push the ps4 platform now
you're probably thinking Dark Souls 2
has already released but the interesting
thing is here that the director of Dark
Souls and Demon's Souls Miyazaki wasn't
director for Dark Souls 2 and everyone
knows that it's his genius behind those
games he left in 2012 to pursue other
projects while Dark Souls 2 was handled
by directors Tommy Hiro Shibuya and you
eat an amira queue the credits for the
three souls games first thing you'll
notice is that Dark Souls 2 has a giant
staff which reflects the larger budget
the game got now the text in red shows
people who have worked on all three
games the most important thing to get
from this is that many of the higher-ups
from previous games know
longer exists on dark souls2 his credits
so it's likely that they're working on
something else rather than them leaving
a successful company user Psycho Mantis
has a really good analysis of the
credits over on neogaf and that's linked
in the description lastly though let's
talk about the rumors before this an
Atlas PR manager mentioned in February
this year that he could 100% confirm
that there won't be a demon souls -
shortly after this though he amended his
statement saying it's Sony's call this
sounds about right
considering that Atlas doesn't even own
the IP so Sony doesn't need to keep them
in the loop on projects if they don't
want to it's more likely he meant we
won't be publishing demon souls - and
now for the biggest piece of evidence
from neogaf user demonite now this guy
is pretty much confirmed to be a Sony
employee and the mind-blowing thing is
he's dropped a bunch of hints in the
past about a ps4 exclusive sole spin-off
in the past he said whatever Miyazaki is
doing I'm sure all souls fans will enjoy
it myself included and here's where we
come full circle the same user said on
the 16th of January this year that Demon
Souls 2 will be a whole different beast
even further back than that he said in
2013 that 2013 s TGS will be a beast of
a show
so while demon souls - or project beast
didn't show at TGS 2013 like this
supposed sony employee thought it might
its surface now in 2014 in this form so
what I should do now as a reputable Dark
Souls uploader is encourage you to be
cautiously optimistic and remain
cautiously optimistic myself [ __ ] that
though I'm gonna go full-on hypetrain
with this [ __ ] can you believe this is
happening a little while ago I mentioned
that there were rumors floating around
about demon souls - and ever since then
I had it on my mind I thought wouldn't
it be amazing if Sony were to fund Demon
Souls 2 and if Frome had to separate
soul series going along their own
separate paths it makes so much sense on
Sony's part they need exclusives to sell
their games and I don't know if there's
a community more passion
than ours it seems like from software
didn't just get a larger staff just so
they could make a better dark souls2
they might have hired a larger staff so
they could effectively work on two
branches of the source franchise and as
much as I hate to draw comparisons to
Call of Duty I imagine it could be like
how Call of Duty has two dev teams they
have Infinity Ward and they have
Treyarch working on yearly iterations of
the same game unlike Call of Duty I
doubt I could get sick of Souls though
but feel free to quote me on that in 10
years in regards to the screenshots
let's see what kind of game were looking
at the combat scene makes it look almost
like a traditional Souls game with a
melee combat scene however the time
period seems to be different and you can
see here that they have shotguns or
blunderbusses alongside cutlasses or
sabers and the time period there makes
me think that it's a sort of late 16th
or
early 17th century and since I just
mentioned it let's talk about those guns
in a Souls game so many people recoil
from this idea but why ranged weapons
aren't something new in a Souls game and
there's a lot they could do with it if
you just give it a little bit of thought
guns do sound overpowered but perhaps
ammo is really hard to come by who knows
the screenshots have this real van
helsing or Castlevania heir to them and
the guns really add to that I don't know
about you guys but I'm keen to gun down
demons in a horrific Victorian era Souls
game aren't you one of the comments by
the original poster of all these
pictures you've been looking at was that
he saw the text this is a nightmare and
I can imagine that being a theme the
dark crumbling castles and graveyard
give a really good horror flavor and
while this is present in Dark Souls and
Demon's Souls I would never say that
it's a real core theme I'd classify
Demon Souls as I guess a medieval horror
and Dark Souls is more of a high fantasy
some of these screens in the screenshots
are more outright creepy almost like you
could imagine a wolf howling in the
distance you know I'd like to see that
feeling or that atmosphere explored so I
suppose that this could be two things it
could be a direct sequel to the demon
souls universe perhaps titled demon
souls 2 or it could be a spiritual
successor to the souls franchise with a
different name
named beast souls or something of the
like what would you prefer there's not
really a right or wrong answer while you
might want to get answers for the
universe of demon souls you might also
want that feeling of exploring a
completely new world and for example I
was always a little bit disappointed
that they went with Dark Souls 2 even
though I knew they would well we got a
few more answers about the Dark Souls
universe there's a lot to be said for
exploring a brand-new universe like we
did in the transition from demon souls
to Dark Souls so yeah I'd love to see a
new world but it's impossible to tell if
it will be though though there is one
reference to demon souls that you guys
might recognize and it's in the word
beasts the old one the main antagonist
of demon souls drops the beasts demon
soul the talisman of beasts also
revealed one of the biggest twists in
demon souls that clerics were getting
their power from the old one just like
the witches they hated so much were
Demon Souls can also end with the loss
of soul sorceries and with guns present
in project based s-- it almost makes me
think that advancements in technology
could have replaced advancements in soul
magics just food for thought but there
definitely is this reference to bastes
in Demon Souls and as for the gameplay
there's no saying which way it will go
this time period might mean a lack of
shields and heavy armor and I imagine
more emphasis on explosives people are
throwing around ideas regarding vampires
werewolves and all the ideas just
floating around are really exciting with
Sony rumored to be at the helm and this
ps4 they have that lacks games I can't
imagine this game being cross-platform
because it would be one hell of a system
seller for Sony I know I would buy a ps4
for this game without a second thought
even though I play on PC the ps4 is
already the more powerful more
affordable console all it lacks is games
and this would seal the deal for me but
would you be getting a ps4 for this or
do you already have one does this sort
of thing annoy you let me know in the
comments right below that like button
Demon Souls is an absolutely brilliant
game and if you're a Souls fan I stand
by the fact that it's almost worth the
ps3 purchase the atmosphere in that game
just hasn't been trumped by a source
game yet in my opinion now Fromm's
probably going to let Dark Souls to sit
for a while
with this rumor I can imagine more
regular iterations of this franchise
which can't be a bad thing in my eyes so
keep your eyes peeled at e3 guys we
might have a really Souls filled future
ahead of us this series just keeps
getting bigger and bigger and this might
prove that it's yet to hit its full
stride I'll keep you updated if we hear
any more news feel free to subscribe if
you haven't already and I'll see you
guys all next time
and if you appreciated some of my videos
in the past you might want to become
part of a small group who Kindle this
channel click the bonfire to check it
out later guys